35 de texto para a china após a dell o
lado diz o autor que quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito em mim jamais um vídeo e
o estrago de que vai finais é fredes que
é um se eu fosse me perder muito
inclusive nos jogos rift e castro é o
pessoal para burlar a cueca com a fiesc
hoje pessoal eu vou fazer é a questão
night um então não fala faz a escalada
xix tomado por uma próxima
dependo do vosso feedback é hoje então
eu vou experimentar a noite experimentar
a noite saí com os rita e esforços de
apoiar em muito este vídeo vou fazer
então é questão night 2011 2020 com
óculos rift vou tentar passar e eu vou
tentar não vou conseguir disse 'você já
põe este vídeo então por lapso alegou
que para os jogos têm que tirar o chapéu
com o primeiro lá e vamos lá pessoal ser
isto vai ser muito os amigos meus que j
entre o santos e sim um fio solto e cá
estamos nós pessoal da noite sete e meia
noite vocês já sabem que eu tenho que
conseguir sobreviver até às seis da
manhã perceberam o pagamento não é para
sair de casa irá ajudar mas com ganhos
na casa com gasolina convém agora vamos
lavar o aek é que não foi nem aí se esta
noite é muito complicada por isso já
prontos a ti precisa que o pato oc1 de
capital subiu para quinta na festa tá
aqui né na mesa com chapéus outra coisa
este jogo não foi completamente adaptado
para alguns riffs tentou usar um
software que me converte o sinal do jogo
para os óculos risco logo isso aqui é um
pouco confuso de usar mas eu fiz os
possíveis porque vocês me pedem muito
mesmo este fait fredes nos jogos hits
se eu falar aqui alguns botões é
preocupa mesmo disso então não chamem de
novo e não é anda lá câmara nesta láááá
pronta já vou ser apanhado e não
consegui ser hoje eu vou ser apanhado
agora
não falou
amy 4 mil para estudos e sendo logo não
é os que vêm atrás nem o pato já sair eu
vou levantar aquele livro baixado em
troca espera é que gastamos nós através
de pessoal desta vez eu vou tentar
acertar nos botões de tempo é muito
complicado mesmo usar esta porcaria mas
vamos lá ok dois já desapareceram o pato
e o coelho já parceiro nessa tal freire
só falar o fred ok o fred eo pior - mala
e não só ficar atentos às portas não é
porque eu sou um santo muito grossista
já o início não é lá onde a questão
estão pertinho não-fato ok o pato está
na cozinha ou gasto em 2000 já saí calma
é de fato e não roda onde estão não só
na questão pessoal e não saiam daqui
estão ok o foxy o fox está ali dentro
quieto eu acho o metal 418 que o qual
estava calma calma calma tá aqui o
sequestro o meu carro você perceber que
está na porta está na porta da qual pato
eu estava destruindo o sapato não calma
está tudo mas saiu daqui entrar de graça
disse calma calma calma pessoal
instrumento muito medo nos jogos reef
apesar de chutar assim tão e bem
adaptado e escutar a minha frente logo
estão na minha frente instrumento mais
mengo e e eo ataque não terá que os
sapatos e pintar é o meu calma muito
medo eu não estou lá pra estourar por
cima por isso não é simplesmente não faz
nada
o hulk está conectado e pinto é pinto
adaptar a porta também usa picchu para a
porta como se eu não soubesse como isso
não sobre os filhos da mãe não sempre
juntos
calma calma estou que os dois eu já tô
com e não conseguir a minha bateria fez
38 eu acho que ela abra a porta lá não
posso testar 30 pilhas já meu ainda é
uma da manhã quando a questão é você que
não ser que atua sob sigilo por tempo só
vocês viram foi mesmo por pouco
e ouve um ruído vocês já ouviram isto
alguém da pimel alguém de perto de mim
eu tô mais de 30 as portas pessoal porco
z pinto amarelo eo zé coelho aparece
muito aqui
nesta sexta à noite de hoje parece muito
o uganda olha fala aneel a falar em uma
pessoa channel já percebeu que a porta
não está
não eu vou é preciso perceber que eu já
saí já saí não na pele o que está a
passar não consiga por ter direito
também de outros hits vegetal com os
games está tudo bem tudo bem
anda louco direto ao meu irmão beira
prontos e empenhado em ganhar a liga
calma calma calma já só quebra anda o
consumidor ganhará que não ok de água
calma eu achar que é souza coelho tenha
medo mesmo medo do zé pinto meu beijo
não vai deixar apanhar não vou vou não
vou está sempre aí quando eu achar a
câmera vai por ser eu já saí eu já saí
outra vez a mesma coisa que ficar para
trás na hora que os jogos que estão à
sua frente basta citar a mesma pois é
desta vez está tudo mais calmo e eu vou
eu vou conseguir passar esta sexta à
noite ou não eu já sei que é impossível
porque se outra vez vai quatro horas
para passar isto não é coisa só consegui
que eu vou para passarem mais rápido não
é em um táxi em cápsulas ser instrumento
muito medo aqui meu o z foxy jattak
espreitarem deixe lá em cima
os jogos serão todos buscamos o acordo
já foi embora lá o septuagenário que não
um dos seqüestros é pinto vai atrás meu
eu não sempre tirar o com um do outro
meu calma
isso é coisa está aqui em causa é pinto
que a porta
se possível o que é eu quero eu quero
comer na copa
sep pinto bronze com 2 mil executados
curto discurso vão apanhar uns vão
ganhar eu usarei heranças você cuida
apareci muito meu tapas e muito rock
anda eu ainda aqui
o cep não tapar ser estanque xiita que é
suspeito eu vai aparecer do nada eu já
saí porque está aqui na minha espera
aqui ao pé da cozinha né
calma com muita calma arquivamos ver as
portas com mais calma lá vão os jogos
que está trabalhando está em falta em
fred que o fred já que o fred vai comer
meu o fred vai comer meu toque o frame
olha pra mim que eu te amo cara a cara
pra mim que só vocês não têm noção do
japão de caraças
o fred vai aparecer aqui eu já saí eu já
saí eu não sai daqui e vai embora
eu tava de trípoli freiem a ganhar e dar
calma tu não vais buscar a cueca hoje
com isto porque por que tu tens que te
esquecer ainda hoje caso não pode jogar
a qualquer época que ela chamava então é
em dólar
abr isso ok é boa só embora o fred em
destaque desta forma a justificar porque
com este finais e fred espero que vocês
tenham gostado isso queremos realmente
ver a noite 20 20 20 20 com alguns hits
deixa o vosso apoio
o aik favorito fiquem bem e até a
próxima